[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es wieder ein richtig
leckeres rezept dass ben jerry's kam mir
schon super gut bei euch ab heute gibt's
nochmal ein nachgemacht video und zwar
werde ich das sneakers eis nachmachen
sneakers ich glaube jeder kennt jeder
liebt also ben jerry's wenn ich das
probiere werde ich schon süchtig und
sneakers eis auch und bounty eis essen
so die drei wo ich sagen muss da kann
ich leider nicht aufhören bei allen
anderen eissorten kann ich glaube ich
echt widerstehen ich glaube ich nicht so
der große eis essen außer bisher
fruchteis so selbstgemachtes gesundes
aber es ist schon so eine suchtgefahr
deswegen mache ich das heute für euch
nach einer richtig einfache variante
ohne spezielle eis form wirklich super
easy könnt ihr zu hause ganz einfach
nachmachen
ich zeige euch mal die zutaten die ich
für die eismasse brauche dafür verwenden
sich 600 gramm sahne 400 gramm gesüßte
kondensmilch 200 gramm erdnussbutter das
ist die cremige 50 gramm marshmallows
auf 100 gramm gesalzene erdnüsse und
etwas karamell creme
ich nehme jetzt zuerst die sahne die
kommt in ein hohes gefäß und wird dann
steif geschlagen und die sollte wirklich
richtig schön kalt sein genau wie alle
anderen zutaten außer die erdnussbutter
denn wenn die kalt ist dann lässt sich
nicht mehr gut verrühren
die sahne ist schon mal fertig jetzt
tausche ich kurz die behälter und nehme
jetzt einfach eine andere schüssel und
da gebe ich jetzt die anderen zutaten
rein also erdnussbutter dann die süße
kondensmilch und ich sehe jetzt hier
auch schon die ist richtig schön
dickflüssig das ist auch die richtige
also die normale kondensmilch es einfach
zu flüssig ihr braucht wirklich die
gesüßte die gezuckerte kondensmilch und
daher kommt dann auch diese tolle eis
konsistenz dann ein bisschen marshmallow
fleisch
ist nicht zwingend ein muss aber es ist
echt gut jetzt die zutaten kurz
verrühren
es riecht einfach jetzt schon wie
snickers und jetzt kommt hier die sache
rein und wird vorsichtig untergehoben
erstmal nur teil ein röhren wie gesagt
spare ich mir jetzt dadurch dass ich
jetzt kondensmilch und seine benutzer
einfach diesen herd prozess also ich
muss nichts auf dem herd kochen keine
eismasse könnt ihr natürlich auch machen
da bleibt einfach mehr zutaten und
natürlich auch mehr arbeit weil die
wasser erst mal gekocht werden muss
beziehungsweise erhitzt werden muss und
dann nochmal abgekühlt werden muss und
somit der variante habt ihr einfach ein
schnelles eis und war alles super
einfach und gelingt sicher
das ist jetzt die ice grundmasse und ich
nehme jetzt einfach zwei torten ringe
die habe ich auch einen flachen teller
gestellt und unten drunter
frischhaltefolie gelegt die habe ich
jetzt auf 20 zentimeter durchmesser
eingestellt ihr könnt im prinzip auch
tiefe teller nehmen mit frischhaltefolie
auslegen und da das eisels einfüllen
die hälfte hier und die hälfte hier was
riecht schon so gut so gut nach sneakers
und jetzt kommen die erdnüsse und die
karamellsoße zum einsatz also die
erdnüsse einfach drüber streuen und die
karamellsoße darüber gießen
die karamellsoße einfach ein bisschen
drüber dann so leicht durchschaubar
verteilen
jetzt kommt das eis in den
gefrierschrank bis es komplett durch
gefordert das eis ist jetzt gefroren und
ich nehme es jetzt einfach aus dem
tortenring heraus
und jetzt in dreiecke schneiden
das lege ich das eis wieder zurück auf
den teller und fans noch kurz ein und
kann in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
kuvertüre schmelzen hier nehme ich jetzt
voll milch zur türe
obwohl ich ein großer fan von zartbitter
kuvertüre bin aber voll milch habe ich
halt auch auf den original sneakers
daher jetzt voll witz und da mache ich
jetzt wieder die zwei drittel ein
drittel methode das heißt zwei drittel
erhöht sich über dem warmen wasserbad
schmelzen
neben es dann vom wasserbad herunter und
dann kommt das restliche drittel dazu
zum herunterkühlen
jetzt kommt ihr das restliche drittel
dazu und noch ein bisschen kokosöl damit
die kuvertüre ein bisschen geschmeidiger
wird aber trotzdem einen schönen knack
hat jetzt einfach nur noch höheren bist
du schön geschmolzen ist
jetzt nehme ich ja einen holz stehen den
stecke ich hier hinten ins eis rein das
ist jetzt kein muss aber wenn ihr es
entstehen haben wollt dann das ist ganz
cool und überdies jetzt erstmal die
oberseite mit dem mit der kuvertüre
wenn ich das so zu aufwendig ist dann
können sie auch einfach die dreiecke auf
einem teller servieren bisschen
kuvertüre darüber gießen karamellsoße
erdnüsse und herzlich
direkt ein paar erdnüsse drauf
jetzt ist es fertig und die jungs können
probieren morath zimmer kommen der mann
ich habe noch keine zeit
juni helfen der ist voll im stress er
ist gradlinig weiß der unterschied
zwischen schweißen und schwitzen nicht
wieder voll zur die war ja hier ist in
sneakers oder aber es sollte schon noch
mal da streut bist du oder es ist
übrigens keine produktplatzierung für
sneakers genau ich habe deren eis
einfach nur nach gemacht genau ich habe
jedes mal angst wenn sowas macht dass
ich irgendwann eine anzeige mit kommen
wegen produktpiraterie das kommandieren
die stirn china verwehrt für wird man
mit ihrem fast alles möglich und ich
erschöpft was gibt es noch zerstreut
ja du hast ist das eis nach gemacht okay
ich war schon mal sneakers nachgemacht
und sneakers ohne sneakers ja selber
gemacht genau um was es geht -
allergiker sollten vielleicht nicht nach
wir haben könnten dies nicht was anderes
machen was schwierig wegen erdnussbutter
aber man genug gewesen
ich glaube es ist vielleicht so aber ich
finde dass necas allgemein so süß weil
ich erfreue mich schokolade mag das ist
mir der spaß aber ich habe nochmals
alles probiert und so kommen sie auch
mehr gang zum regen kleiner das geht
aber sind großen schaffe ich niemals nie
geschmeckt hat
wieso so etwas ja noch karamell trennen
und echt genial aber damit geht es doch
ein bisschen weniger zucker
was das problem ich du hast diese
kondensmilch diese gezuckerte
erdnussbutter und sahne gut macht kann
man weglassen 50 euro
gerade während dieser zeit gerade mit
zwei kilo an der k 50 gramm mal meter
flach weglassen
aber ansonsten man kann natürlich diese
eismasse auch machen mit zucker und
milch und sahne
aber dann hat man halt ein bisschen
arbeit am herd aber da kann man dann
zurückziehen krimis älter und damit eine
fotografie rickens essen für mich würde
ich jetzt noch mal machen aber mit peter
kurator weil ich bin hat mich gewarnt
pass auf ich bin ich ein fallmanagement
bietet komet übernehmen da scheint es
immer wichtig ist und was noch weg
machen das sind zwar schnell noch ein
marshmallow blick ganz weglassen oder
weglassen kann man an schatten gibt so
guten kondensmilch auf die normale
konsens mit niemand die es zufällig da
fehlt dann einfach dann wird es so
christa lich und dann schmilzt sofort
aber ich bin peter venn aber so ist es
halt eure gratis neben wonach es bei uns
überhaupt das ganze stück hummer
wir müssen in sneakers verpackung
reingemacht hätte ich 100 prozent
original sneakers produkte halten was
kann schluss war es auch mit netz machen
der tennisplatz kennt jemand von euch
ist eine gelbe verpacken kennt das
jemand kennst du nah zu mir ja ja ja
rot-gelb dichtes netz ist übrigens mein
trail riegel regel also was hat er uns
vielleicht kaufen ja also nazis richtig
genial was ich dein lieblings regel ja
okay ich hätte das nicht gedacht und was
ist einiges regeln was bist du bounty
hounds es bei dir ja ich bin nicht so
der schoko süßigkeiten keine aber sobald
wir werden dann als minister
celebrations form entstehen dann greife
ich zu bauen
die orders des neckars als kleine erst
dann gehen sie mal in die kommentare was
eure und ist und ob ihr netz kennen und
was ich als nächstes wird nach machen
soll dann genau aufschreiben was eure
lieblings regel
und was soll ich als nächstes machen
egal was die presse
regel von capri eis machen kaffee kommen
den strand geht alles süßigkeiten aber
weiß nicht was das ist ist es nicht
einfach nur orangensaft orangensaft mit
zucker auf dem steht dass pastinaken ist
ja klar ist auch ihn zurück ja okay ist
ja auch ein gemüse aber er hat sie
zucker drin wäre okay alles lag einem
jahr
das match im jahr an imz minsk ich hab
noch eingefräst sich deren schutz gebe
es könnt euch das an
wir müssen mal ein fitnessstudio hier
einrichten frauen
[Musik]